hello everyone and welcome to another
parallel programming in super computing
tutorial with use of MPI I'm for our
uses we're using MPI for PI so we're
going to use Python for this in the last
video I showed you guys how we can
install this and all the previous videos
I showed you guys how you can build your
own supercomputer out of raspberry PI's
and now in this video we're just gonna
take it a step further learn one more
thing about MPI for pi mean yes so again
keep in mind that you need to have the
whatever script that you're working on
that you're gonna run using MPI needs to
be located in the same directory you
know like the same path on all the
machines again like I mentioned before
you can do some sorcery with this by
having different contents of that so the
masternodes sometimes will have a
specific file and all the worker nodes
will have another specific file just
don't have the same name finally I'm
using SSH here and I'm gonna code the
script in idle on my main computer so
I'm just gonna coat it straight into
here now just keep in mind that if
you're doing the same thing so if you're
coding the script on your main computer
you do need to you know either use SCP
to put it on on your other you know in
your worker node your master node or you
can just sudo nano and type straight in
to here so just for example here where I
think we went to desktop and s CT v or
call CT s CT and right now we've got s
CT to PI so what you could do is sudo
nano stt 2.5 right so you could program
all of this straight in and it actually
does do the highlighting I didn't think
it did pretty sure if you're like
straight on your PI it doesn't
necessarily do that but anyway so there
it is anyway so we could program it
straight in but I'm gonna program in
idle anyways so anyway so just as a side
there so with that let's go ahead and
get started this one's gonna be pretty
simple but again
the basic opening pretty much every time
here's gonna be from MPI for pi import
MPI and then the next thing that we
always pretty much want to do is calm e
equals NP I homes.com underscore world
okay now what we're going to want to do
first is I guess we can just we can
continue because I print my rank is so
we'll do that again
comm reg and now what I want to show you
guys is just simple conditionals so we
can use conditional programming here
again so what we can do is something
like this so we could say if comm rank
equals 1 so 1 is gonna be your worker
node most likely it's gonna go by the
ranks in that machine file but let's say
like well for me 0 is going to be the
master node since that's the first
listing there and that one would be the
worker node but regardless will just say
print doing the task of rank 1 and then
we can come down here and if con rank
equals 0 brain doing the task rank 0 and
finally we can say if comm rank equals 2
doing the task we'll save that and now
again I'm gonna use SCP to put this file
on both PI's if you program it in you
can type it twice if you so chose I'm
just gonna click and drag these so once
you've done that I'll head over to your
master node and I'm assuming I can just
hit the up arrow and get to the last
time we typed this show enough so you
should be able to do that otherwise you
know use this command basically your
first part is MPI run to open MPI same
thing for everybody
number of processors you can make
whatever number you want machine file
where's the machine file located and
then Python and then run what
where that file is located since we're
in that directory we can just say this
so we don't want SEC to though we want
to run NC t3 so let's go ahead and run
that see how we do sure enough we get my
rank 0 doing the task of rank 0 my rank
is one doing the task of rank 1 let's
run out one more time I was hoping you'd
see him switch up but I guess maybe they
won't so now what we can do is we can
come over here and we can say number of
processors and instead this time say 3
coups say 3 and we should see the rank 2
here and sure enough there we go so rank
1 2 and 0 okay so real basic but I just
want to introduce the idea of using
conditional conditionals here so you can
use if and you can of course use else
and Elif and all of this stuff well what
makes it interesting is that you're kind
of using these conditionals between each
other so you kind of have to understand
that it literally is gonna run the
script on each machine but then it
shares the information between them so
anyway like I said before there's gonna
be as weak as you get down further
deeper into the rabbit hole you'll find
that you'll have to do a lot of trial
and error to see like what you can get
away with kind of like when you first
started programming so anyways that's
gonna conclude this video in the next
video we're just gonna take it a little
bit one step further and learn a new
command actually let's see we'll
probably learn yeah really just one more
command there and then we'll do just
some simple math and just show the
sharing of some simple math so anyways
that's going to glue this video
hopefully you guys are enjoying if you
have any questions or comments or you're
confused on something feel free to leave
it below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support in the
subscriptions until next time